okay let's talk about joe biden on
immigration now
joe biden has made it clear that the
immediate next priority is coveted
relief
i've already criticized and said it
should have been done already
it hasn't we're hoping that it gets done
soon very soon thereafter
immigration is going to be high on joe
biden's list now
much of what joe biden wants to do on
immigration cannot be done
by executive order one bit of good news
is that joe biden
has cancelled the national emergency
order that donald trump was using
to try to get money for
his border wall joe biden sent a letter
to congress late last week
saying that no further tax dollars will
be spent on the wall
now you might be wondering but there was
no wall
trump promised a wall across the entire
border it never happened what are we
talking about here
that is true but remember that donald
trump
declared a state of emergency over the
southern border in 2019
that allowed him to use some military
funding
for construction of the wall now the
disastrous news
is that trump did manage to spend 25
billion
on the project the unfortunate it's sort
of like a pyrrhic victory that donald
trump had because he was able to obtain
money for the wall
but they were really able to do mostly
some replacement of existing border wall
areas with a new type of wall
and expand it slightly so as far as a
campaign promise
trump failed on having a wall across the
entire border
that was his promise he made it very
very clearly and said that was a
first-term
accomplishment that he would have didn't
happen on the other hand it's
it's good news in the sense that not
much of it
took place and joe biden is able to shut
down
this emergency uh declaration of
emergency
and to stop pulling any more money from
the military for
the wall this is the continued use of
executive orders by joe biden
to undo many of the disasters that
donald trump did of course
much like debt and deficit executive
orders have become a political football
if your guy or gal is in power and using
executive orders
then you say these executive orders are
required and necessary to undo the
damage of the previous president
if your guy or gal is not in the oval
office
then you call executive orders at least
if you're a republican
a um sort of authoritarian
tyrannical a circumvention of the normal
legislative process that's
that's the way it's been for a while
it's pretty similar to the debt and
deficit
uh but it is a good thing that joe biden
has been doing this particularly
when the republican party is more
obstructionist arguably than it has ever
been
um the exact numbers are that 80 miles
of new barriers were built
during the trump administration where
there were none and otherwise there were
just replacements of existing parts of
border wall or border fencing so i think
this is an important time to just
remind you that we know a lot about what
circumstances call for a wall and what
circumstances do not
one of the really interesting things is
that even without the wall remember
trump only added 80 miles without a wall
across the entire border as promised by
trump
um trump regularly claimed border
crossings
are lower than ever so that's proof
that it's if you believe that that's
proof
that it is not a wall that reduces
border crossings and of course
we've long studied the reasons why it is
absurd to spend
these ungodly amounts of money on a wall
we know that
and we've seen examples of being able to
scale the wall
with about 100 in parts from any
hardware store home depot lows that type
of place
it is easily defeated number two uh you
have a significant portion of people who
are in the united states
illegally who have overstayed visas or
came
for uh tourism and never left and they
are mostly
flying in not crossing the physical
border
at the u.s mexico border and then lastly
if you want to think about the best roi
the best return on investment
for dealing with the issue of
undocumented immigration
we really should be approaching this
from why are people
wanting to come to the united states to
begin with
understanding the economic conditions in
the source countries not just mexico but
further south as well
and working with those countries and if
we are supposed to be
sort of agnostic to how the money is
spent as long as it effectively deals
with the undocumented immigration
problem
then you would think that the right
would be open to the ideas of economists
and others who have said well
let's instead of building a wall that
can be defeated and won't actually
address a lot of the people that fly in
and overstay visas or just never leave
when they come for for vacation
let's actually spend money by improving
economic circumstances in some of these
source countries
now the the problem is we know that for
them
a big aspect of this is not just doing
what's most effective
it's what doing what feels right based
on their
uh framework of morality as they would
call it or or maybe as we would describe
it
and um to them it would seem wrong
in some way to give money to improve
a country when people are coming here
illegally it just
doesn't feel right to the ideology
that many of these right-wingers are
committed to but study after study as
we've outlined in our long-form piece
about this issue
confirms that that actually would be the
most effective way to curb
undocumented immigration to the united
states so the micro story
joe biden has cut that emergency
declaration there is not even a
mechanism
with which you could pull money from the
military to build the wall
next step is biden's got to deal with
daca and it is finally time with
democrats controlling the white house
the house and the senate if it's not
going to happen now
i don't know that it will ever happen
it's finally time
to really do the immigration reform
we've been talking about for i mean it's
been 15 years or longer at this point
send me your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at d pacman
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video